let's talk about the eight dangerous
signs that you should never ignore
now before i begin let me just give you
a disclaimer
now make sure you check with your doctor
before implementing the suggestion of
checking with your
doctor well maybe i don't need a
disclaimer in this video
but anyway if you've been watching my
videos uh sometimes you might have got
the impression that i'm against
medicine or medical doctors that is
absolutely not true i respect
medical doctors i respect competent
medical doctors when i busted my elbow
in an accident they took me from a very
serious situation where i had
30 little pieces of bone fragments and
put me back together again so i'm able
to use my elbow so i highly respect
competent medical professionals the
challenge i have is with the system in
general and just the lack of emphasis on
your foods
and nutrition it's just not taught in
medical school and unfortunately big
pharma has
too much control over the medical
profession in which these drugs can be
set up to last only 24 hours and then
you got to take another drug and
unfortunately it's this kind of setup
where the patient is becoming an atm for
big pharma but let me just get into the
eight dangerous signs that you should
never ignore and you should go see your
doctor to get more information
number one
excuse me um a cough now there is acute
coughs which only lasts like three weeks
and they usually
go away by themselves you have sub-acute
coughs that could last three to eight
weeks okay then you have this chronic
cough
and the person's like just always
clearing their throat and they're
coughing for a long period of time
usually after eight weeks now if you've
tried everything you've tried zinc you
tried vitamin d
you even tried calcium calcium lactate
which is a non-dairy type of calcium
which works really good for these
chronic coughs and if that still has not
resolved the cough then you need to go
get it checked out and get more
information especially if there's
difficulty swallowing if you have a
fever if you check and your lymph nodes
are still enlarged there's something
going on and especially if the cough is
getting worse all right number two uh
hold on a second let me just make sure
you see this
oh yeah loss of vision
that was my dry sense of humor
in one or both eyes
that could potentially be a blood clot
in the retinal artery okay which could
mean various things it could mean that
you had a tia which means you could have
had a mini stroke or a transient
ischemic attack now the problem with a
mini stroke is that you may be at risk
of getting a second stroke in fact if
you had a mini stroke there's a 17
chance that you may have another stroke
within 90 days so you want to get it
checked out anytime you have a stroke
you want to get to the emergency room as
fast as possible so then they can give
you a certain medication to thin the
blood and prevent any further damage
now it could be a brain tumor it could
be glaucoma it could be any number of
things i remember i had a patient whose
husband was coming in with her
and he just
had the worst diet in the world in fact
one day he let me check him out and i
had him lay on the table and i was
chucking him out and his extremities his
arms and his legs completely went
dead his extremities just lost
feeling and function okay that's a bad
circulation problem you would think he
would do something about it now he was
an expert at ignoring these symptoms
okay
until eventually he came in
uh blind well guess what he had diabetes
and he didn't do anything about it it
didn't change his diet he didn't do
anything so now he's blind
so a loss of vision could mean
something related to diabetes as well
all right
next one
drooping or weakness on one side of your
body all right now that could either be
that you had a stroke or it's an early
sign that a stroke is on its way
and
over seven million people a year die of
strokes
now there's an acronym uh
fast we have
f which is face droop okay
a arm week
s speech difficulty means t time to call
an easy way to remember it all right
number four
let's say you have this changing mole
okay
this mole in your body that is
starting to grow okay
that means you need to get it checked
out because you want to rule out
something called a melanoma which is
skin cancer now there's another acronym
i'm going to show you it's a b c d e
okay let's start with a
is it asymmetrical so usually with a
mole you have a very symmetrical
uh shape all right but with melanoma
it's usually
asymmetrical all right the border around
a mole is very smooth and even
but the border around a melanoma is very
rough it's jagged it has a
non-smooth border all right c a melanoma
will have different colors okay a mole
pretty much stays
consistently the same color kind of a
brown or darker brown but a melanoma
could turn like yellow blue green
red so if you see your mole changing
then get it checked out okay next one is
diameter when you have a melanoma the
size of it is usually greater than six
millimeters okay that would be the about
a fourth of an inch or the size of a
pencil eraser but if you have a penny
it's about a fourth of that because a
penny is about i think it's 19
millimeters so it would be one-fourth of
a penny so moles are smaller melanomas
are larger all right e
evolution is it changing is it evolving
is it a growing suspect melanoma
get it checked now just so you know i
did a video on melanomas and
i talked about sun you can watch that
video i'll put a link down below you
know there's a lot of opinions on sun
but sun has a lot of great therapeutic
benefits
but when you're out in the sun too long
and you get burnt that's when you can
start increasing your risk for certain
types of problems with the skin but if
you're not letting your skin burn
it can be very therapeutic in different
ways because sometimes the people are so
freaked out they stay in the house all
the time to never go out in the sun and
they don't realize there's a huge
benefit of just being outside all right
number five let's say you start getting
a frequent and excessive thirst okay
you're extremely thirsty
just out of the blue your mouth is dry
you didn't exercise it's not hot out
you're not taking a lot of potassium or
an electrolyte
and also you're not taking a diuretic
but you're extremely thirsty and you
have to pee a lot well that could mean
that you have diabetes because
what's happening is the kidneys are
going to dump this excess sugar and
wherever the sugar goes the water goes
so
get it checked check your blood sugars
of course if you've been watching my
channel you probably are not going to
have this because you've been
implementing all these wonderful ideas
about going on a ketogenic diet and
doing intermittent fasting so this is
really about you know your friends and
family that might have this symptom just
because i've heard stories about people
having super high levels of blood sugars
but not knowing it and then having all
these symptoms i mean you can literally
go into a coma if your blood sugars are
too
high so
you won't have to worry about that if
you
keep your carbs on the low side okay
number six
resting tremors okay now that can happen
because you're tired it can happen
because you haven't slept that well it
can happen right after exercise but it
could also potentially be the early
signs of parkinson's disease okay so if
you start noticing a resting tremor and
your gait is slowed down and you become
very very stiff and rigid and you have a
masked face where your face it looks
very very serious or very depressed yet
you're not depressed or serious
that could be early signs of parkinson's
but also it could be that you have
what's called metabolic alkalosis so
your ph your blood ph is on the alkaline
side okay
tremors is one of the symptoms and so
if you also have like tetany like
twitching or muscle cramps it just could
be a ph problem so it's just something
good to get checked out all right number
seven
some changes in the breast tissue so
let's say you're female and you notice a
lump in the breast or in your armpit
you might want to get that checked out
because that could be the early signs of
a tumor but here's the thing
there's a thing called fibrocystic
breast okay where
there's a
cyst developing in the breast tissue and
it's not necessarily cancer
but it is a cyst which is different so i
just want to mention this because
the most powerful remedy for that it
seems to work like nearly 100 of the
time
is seek help okay because the iodine in
seek help
helps to
modulate or control
estrogen dominance in the body
and so it really dramatically will get
rid of
ovarian cysts and cysts in the breast
tissue so if you do have some lump and
you take
sea kelp and it doesn't go away get it
checked out last one
let's say you have blood in the stool
okay
you don't want to ignore that but
realize it could be a hemorrhoid it
could be
some ulcer in your large intestine let's
see you have some type of inflammation
and in your large intestine or even your
small intestine that can create blood in
the stool or let's not rule out that you
just had some beets that can make your
stool red
or it could be colorectal cancer and so
it's very good to know about this as
early as possible so you can do
something about it so the point of this
video is not to ignore your body's
communication to you
but to
get more data in your evaluation so you
can have knowledge
and do something about it now if you
haven't seen my video
on how to get so healthy that you can
prevent and avoid all these things right
here
i put it right here check it out
you